toymakers were inventive
georg christopher used to live and work
near here he made beautiful wooden toys
including this duck a rather innovative
and magical playing card dispenser
it would be even nicer if my duck were
to give me exactly the card i need in a
game
for example as jack of clubs
and lo and behold here it is
roland wozniack used to be a textile
engineer in former east germany
today he's a jack of all trades
my name is my name is roland vosniak
i'm a filmmaker magician and tour guide
sonoberg has a unique backdrop from the
days when the place was called a world
center of toy making
roland wozniack dresses up as a
fictitious character and shows
visitors the city with his guided tours
and documentary films about zonneberg
as the ghost of toys he haunts the
streets of his town
its toy making heritage goes back to the
16th century
his first tip is the german toy museum
home to the oldest collection in the
country
a museum for the young and old alike
visitors get to see how the production
site has changed over the years
that includes a montage of figures based
on gulliver's travels made in the 19th
century
from bread and dough it wasn't until
later that local toy makers discovered
the wonders of paper mache
the pioneering use of new materials
helped make zonaberg a hub of global toy
production
i've known the place for years but every
time i come here i find something new
and unique
you communicate with the exhibits and
then discover completely new stories
sometimes i listen to them and find new
tales to tell my guests outside
on the tours
the highlight of the collection are the
fairground figures in 1910 the
collection put zonenburg on the map at
the world expo in brussels
roland's second recommendation is the
zonoberg observatory
it was founded in 1925.
it has seven research telescopes an
impressive figure by any standards
the observatory has had an interesting
evolution itself
its creator kuno hofmeister the son of a
toy maker
but after being captivated by the stars
at an early age
he was determined to become an
astronomer as fate would have it his
father's company went bankrupt
it was a disaster for the entire family
but a relief for kuno
now he could focus on his calling and
realize his dream
he built what was then the biggest
observatory in germany
up here on this land overlooking the
zona back
you can still feel a bit of the magic
and enthusiasm of kuno hofmeister
the preservation of the observatory is
thanks to thomas weber
who heads a local association dedicated
to looking after it
it was formed after the collapse of east
germany amidst fears the site would be
shut down
tip number three from roland wozniack is
the dachshula
which is another part of zonnerberg's
rich heritage a pub
established in 1895.
a place where roland can work more of
his magic
he is a popular and welcome guest
these are strange cards here take one
name
not the queen of spades again of course
it is
and he has plenty more tricks up those
sleeves
and hear their language it's best to
come here to the docs
that's where you find that blunt but
warm-hearted atmosphere so typical of
the people of zonabella
over 100 years old and not changed a bit
in the last 50 years
and that's how locals want the pub to
stay
you